comme à chaque étape de notre histoire
avec françois bayrou
nous aurons à faire des propositions
lors des échéances à venir
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons aujourd'hui nous interroger sur
ce qui fonde notre identité et c'est
tout l'objectif d'université centre
université 133,7 une démarche qui
associe des chercheurs les adhérents et
les responsables de notre mouvement pour
définir ensemble
la singularité de notre regard sur les
grands enjeux contemporains
vous êtes invités à contribuer à quatre
grandes thématiques europe et relations
internationales démocratie citoyenneté
et laïcité
[Musique]
développement durable et société
solidarité sur chacun de ces grands
sujets venez contribuer venez donner
votre avis sur la plateforme agorad m
pour alimenter le travail d'université
cent d'entre eux